[Musica]
[Applauso]
primi di gennaio del 72 o dieci anni
sono settimana bianca con la mia
famiglia in un paesino sperduto del
piemonte che una nevicata epocale ha
isolato dal resto del mondo
le autorità ci hanno chiesto di non
uscire all'aperto di restare chiusi nel
nostro hotel perché slavine e valanghe
potrebbero manifestarsi all'improvvisa
renderlo pericoloso anche semplicemente
passeggiare all'esterno per fortuna
l'hotel è stupendo e quindi passiamo le
nostre giornate rinchiusi cantando
suonando mangiando e giocando tra gli
ospiti dell'hotel c'e una fatina bionda
con gli occhi verdi di cui mi innamoro
immediatamente ma che non ho il coraggio
di avvicinare un pomeriggio un ragazzino
un po più intraprendente di mele si
avvicina e le propone una partita a
scacchi
lei accetta e passano tutto il
pomeriggio tra la torre non alfiere
ammiccando guardandosi negli occhi
sorridendo se c'è una cosa
insopportabile
però capisco che gli scacchi sono la
chiave per conoscerla a c'è un piccolo
problema io non so giocare a scacchi
per fortuna tra gli amici che sono in
settimana bianca con noi c'è un amico
dei miei che invece sa giocare a scacchi
il principito da lui gli dico io devo
imparare a giocare a scacchi
lui mi diceva bene ci sediamo e io
pensavo fosse una roba difficile invece
mi sembra banale tutto le mosse sono
intuitive
la mossa del cavallo e geniale ma non ci
trovo niente di complicato
alla sera mi sento pronto
su una notte semin son aspetto il
mattino dopo il mattino dopo per fortuna
nevica continua a nevicare esattamente
con i giorni precedenti
siamo sempre rinchiusi nell'hotel
aspetta un pomeriggio mi precipito dalla
fatina bionda che scoprono chiamarsi
monica e le propongo una partita a
scacchi
lei mi guarda sorride e io le dico sì mi
piacerebbe perché il mio gioco preferito
mento spudoratamente dice volentieri e
iniziano gli succede qualcosa che
proprio non mi sarei mai aspettato
io nuovi pezzi come ho imparato giorno
prima giocando anche di ricordarmi
perché non ho tutto chiarissimo
però mi sforzo lei ha lo sguardo
proiettato nel futuro
lei guarda avanti lei è sempre tre o
quattro mosse oltre mentre io continuo a
muovere i miei pezzi uno dopo l'altro
risultato in poco meno di due ore mi
liquida per tre volte perdendo ogni
interesse nei miei confronti
sono molto deluso ma ve lo stesso tempo
sono straordinariamente un fonico perché
gli scacchi sono entrati nella mia vita
che non riusciranno più e tra l'altro
proprio nel 1972 che è l'anno magico
degli scacchi l'anno della epica sfida
tra bobby fischer e boris spassky
la guerra fredda combattuta sulla
scacchiera la prima volta in cui un
americano diventa campione del mondo di
scacchi è inutile dire che non mi perdo
una partita bobby fischer è il mio idolo
è un misto tra un uomo talentuoso un
genio un pazzoide e guardandolo giocare
io pensavo che comunque gli scacchi
fossero un gioco e quindi come tutti i
giochi puro divertimento mentre invece
mi rendo conto per la prima volta a 10
anni
che gli scacchi forse hanno qualche cosa
che fare con la vita non lo capisco
benissimo in quel momento forse perché
lui stesso bobby fischer diceva gli
scacchi sono la vita io non credo che lo
siano
però capisco perché lui lo dice
innanzitutto perché spesso sono gli
scacchi sono associati all'intelligenza
ed è per questo che perdere una partita
a scacchi e dolorosissimo cioè tutti
sappiamo quanto doloroso perdere una
partita a tennis piuttosto che perdeva
occasione ma con questa associazione
scacchi intelligenza se perdi a scacchi
ti senti stupido garri kasparov uno dei
più grandi campioni di tutti i tempi
quando perse la sua prima partita contro
un computer non sapeva darsene pace
era la prima volta che un campione del
mondo perdeva contro una macchina e quel
campione del mondo a lui però
continuando a studiare le partite di
fisher in particolare mi rendo conto che
essere un professionista degli scacchi
richiede tutta una serie di altre
caratteristiche che vanno oltre
l'intelligenza il talento ci vuole
autonomia di pensiero
una mossa non è buona soltanto perché la
giocata qualcuno prima una mossa è buona
se porta buoni risultati ci vuole
grandissima attenzione il pezzo mossi in
una casella piuttosto che in un'altra
vuol dire perdere una partita già vinta
ci vuole un piano e manuela schiano dei
più grandi scacchisti diceva negli
scacchi è meglio avere un piano
sbagliato piuttosto che non avere nessun
piano diversamente sia alla mercé del
caso ecco io crescendo mi rendo conto
che tutte queste caratteristiche fanno
di uno scacchista un professionista
beh inutile che vi dica non sono mai
diventato un artista professionista
però crescendo messo a punto per
l'intuizione che avevo avuto da bambino
e mi rendo conto che quelle
caratteristiche che fanno di uno
scacchista un professionista possono
fare di un uomo un professionista della
vita e nella vita e si possono
riassumere tutte in quattro parole che
curiosamente iniziano tutte con la
lettera c la prima parola e cultura come
uno scacchista professionista non può
prescindere dallo studio delle partite
dei grandi campioni che l'hanno
preceduto così il professionista non può
dimenticare di studiare coltivare
dall'etimologia di cultura il passato
per poter affrontare le sfide del
presente e del futuro
la seconda parola e competenza come ho
imparato a 10 anni non si diventa
professionisti in un giorno così non si
diventa professionisti della vita
improvvisando ci vuole competenza
competenza è un insieme di conoscenza è
un insieme di esperienza e un insieme di
talento che ti permette di affrontare
qualunque sfida contro qualunque
avversario con la consapevolezza di
poterla vincere
curiosamente competizione e competenza
hanno la stessa radice non si primeggia
nella competizione senza competenza la
terza parola e coerenza
vi ricordate manuel asker ci vuole un
piano anche nella vita ci vuole un piano
perché ogni mossa deve essere il frutto
della mossa precedente soltanto in
questo modo si segue un piano organico
che porta a dei risultati
immaginati evoluti la quarta parola e
coraggio
perché nella vita occorre sì riflettere
ma una volta che si è riflettuto occorre
avere il coraggio di decidere
si sbaglia il 100 per cento delle
decisioni che non si prendono e senza
avere il coraggio di decidere
ci si trova in quella situazione che
negli scatti si chiama zeit not
rimediabile mancanza di tempo e come in
un cocktail i cui ingredienti danno
luogo a un qualcosa che ha il sapore
diverso dai quattro ingredienti che
l'hanno composto
ebbene le quattro parole cultura
competenza coerenza e coraggio
opportunamente miscelate dando luogo
alla visione revisione non è qualcosa di
sovrannaturale o che spetta il genio no
la visione è semplicemente la capacità
di vedere oltre di immaginare
l'inimmaginabile di pensare al presente
guardando al futuro ecco da questa sera
da domani quando dovrete prendere una
decisione
prendetela da professionisti sarà
sicuramente la decisione giusta
grazie
[Applauso]